I was talking to a guy at a party in
California about tech platforms and the
problems they're creating in society and
he said man if the CEOs just did more
drugs and went to Burning Man we
wouldn't be in this mess I said I'm not
sure I agree with you for one thing you
know most of the CEOs have already been
to Burning Man but also I'm just not
sure that watching a bunch of half-naked
people run around and burn things is
really the inspiration they need right
now but I do agree that things are a
mess and so we're gonna come back to
this guy but let's talk about the mess
our climates getting hotter and hotter
it's getting harder and harder to tell
truth from fiction and we've got this
global migratory crisis and just at the
moment when we really need new tools and
new ways of coming together as a society
it feels like social media is kind of
tearing at our civic fabric and setting
us against each other
we've got viral misinformation on
whatsapp bullying on Instagram and
Russian hackers on Facebook and I think
this conversation that we're having
right now about the harms that these
platforms are creating is so important
but I also worry that we could be
letting a kind of good existential
crisis in Silicon Valley go to waste if
the bar for success is just that it's a
little harder for Macedonian teenagers
to publish publish false news the big
question I think is not just what do we
want platforms to stop doing but now
that they've effectively taken control
of our online public square what do we
need from them for the greater good to
me this is one of the most important
questions of our time what obligations
do tech platforms have to us in exchange
for the power that we let them hold over
our discourse and I think
this question is so important because
even if today's platforms go away we
need to answer this question in order to
be able to ensure that the new platforms
that come back are any better so for the
last year I've been working with dr.
Talia Stroud at the University of Texas
Austin and we've talked to sociologists
and political scientists and
philosophers to try to answer this
question and at first we asked you know
if you were Twitter or Facebook and you
were trying to rank content for
democracy rather than for ad clicks or
engagement what might that look like
but then we realized you know this sort
of suggests that this is a information
problem or a content problem and for us
the platform crisis is a people problem
it's a problem about the emergent weird
things that happen when large groups of
people get together and so we turned to
another older idea we asked what happens
when we think about platforms as spaces
we know from social psychology that
spaces shape behavior you put the same
group of people in a room like this and
they're gonna behave really differently
than in a room like this when
researchers put softer furniture in
classrooms participation rates rose by
42% and spaces even have political
consequences when researchers looked at
neighborhoods with parks versus
neighborhoods without after adjusting
for socio-economic factors they found
that neighborhoods with parks had higher
levels of social trust and were better
able to advocate for themselves
politically so spaces shaped behavior
partly by the way they're designed and
partly by the way that they encode
certain norms about how to behave you
know we all know that there are some
behaviors that are okay in a bar that
are not okay in a library and maybe vice
versa and this gives us a little bit of
a clue because there are online spaces
that encode these same kinds of
behavioral norms so for example behavior
on LinkedIn seems pretty good why
because it reads as a workplace
and so people follow workplace norms you
can even see it in the way they dress
and their profile pictures
so if LinkedIn is a workplace what is
Twitter like well it's like a vast
cavernous expanse where there are people
talking about sports arguing about
politics yelling at each other flirting
trying to get a job all in the same
place with no walls no divisions and the
owner gets paid more the louder the
noise is no wonder it's a mess and this
raises another thing that becomes
obvious when we think about platforms in
terms of physical space good physical
spaces are almost always structured they
have rules Silicon Valley is built on
this idea that unstructured space is
conducive for human behavior and I
actually think there's a reason for this
myopia built into the location of
Silicon Valley itself so michele Gelfand
is a sociologist who studies how norms
vary across cultures and she watches how
culture is like Japan which she calls
tight is very conformist very
rule-following and cultures like Brazil
are very loose and you can see this even
in things like how closely synchronized
the clocks are on a city street so as
you can see the United States is one of
the looser countries and the loosest
state in the United States is you got
him California and Silicon Valley
culture came out of the 1970s
Californian counterculture so just to
recap the spaces that the world is
living in came out of the loosest
culture in the loosest state in one of
the loosest countries in the world
no wonder they undervalue structure and
I think this really matters because
people need structure you may have heard
this word enemy it literally means a
lack of norms in French and it was
coined by Emile Durkheim to describe the
vast overwhelming feeling that people
have in spaces without norms enemy has
political consequences
because what gelfand has found is that
when things are too loose people crave
order and structure and that craving for
order and structure correlates really
strongly with support for people like
these guys I don't think it's crazy to
ask if the structuralist nosov online
life is actually feeding anxiety that's
increasing a responsiveness to
authoritarianism so how might platforms
bring people together in a way that
creates meaning and helps people
understand each other and this brings me
back to our friend from Burning Man
because listening to him I realized you
know it's not just that Burning Man
isn't the solution it's actually a
perfect metaphor for the problem you
know it's a great place to visit for a
week this amazing art city rising out of
nowhere and the dust but you wouldn't
want to live there there's no running
water there's no trash pickup at some
point the hallucinogens run out and
you're stuck with a bunch of wealthy
white guys in the dust in the desert
which you know to me is sometimes how
social media feels in 2019 a great fun
hallucinatory place to visit has become
our home and so if we look at platforms
through the lens of spaces we can then
ask ourselves who knows how to structure
spaces for the public good and it turns
out that this is a question people have
been thinking about for a long time
about cities cities were the original
platforms 2-sided marketplace check
place to keep up with old friends and
distant relatives check vector for viral
sharing check in fact you know cities
have encountered a lot of the same
social and political challenges that
platforms are now encountering they've
dealt with massive growth that
overwhelmed existing communities and the
rise of new business models
they've even had new frictionless
technologies that promise to connect
everyone together and that instead
deepened existing social and race
divides but because of this history of
decay and renewal and segregation and
integration cities are the source of
some of our best ideas about how to
build functional thriving communities
faced with a top-down car driven vision
of city life pioneers like Jane Jacobs
said let's instead put human
relationships at the center of urban
design Jacobs and her fellow travelers
like Holly white her editor were these
really great observers of what actually
happened on the street they watched you
know where did people stop and talk when
did neighbors become friends and they
learned a lot
for example they noticed that successful
public places generally have three
different ways that they structure
behavior so there's the built
environment you know that we're gonna
put a fountain here we're gonna put a
playground there but then there's
programming like let's put a band at
7:00 and get to get the kids out and
there's this idea of mayors people who
kind of take this informal ownership of
a space to keep it welcoming and clean
all three of these things actually have
analogs online but platforms mostly
focus on code on what's physically
possible in this space and they focus
much less on these other two softer
social areas what are people doing there
who's taking responsibility for it
so like Jane Jacobs did for Cities
Italia and I think we need a new design
movement for online space one that
considers not just you know how do we
build products that work for users or
consumers how do we make something
user-friendly but how do we make
products that are public friendly
because we need products that don't
serve individuals at the expense of the
social fabric on which we all depend
and we need it urgently because
political scientists tell us that
healthy democracies need healthy public
spaces so the public friendly digital
design movement Italian I imagine asked
this question you know what would this
interaction be like if it was happening
in physical space and it asked the
reverse question what can we learn from
good physical spaces about how to
structure behavior in the online world
for example I grew up in a small town in
Maine and I went to a lot of those town
hall meetings that you hear about and
unlike sort of the storybook version
they weren't always nice like people had
big conflicts big feelings
it was hard sometimes but because of the
way that that space was structured we
managed to land it okay how well here's
one important piece the downcast glance
the dirty look the raised eyebrow the
cough when people went on too long or
lost the crowd they didn't get banned or
blocked or hauled out by the police they
just got this soft negative social
feedback and that was actually very
powerful I think you know Facebook and
Twitter could build this something like
this so I think there are some other
things that online spaces can learn from
offline spaces Holly White observed that
in healthy public spaces there often
many different places that afford
different ways of relating so the picnic
table where you have lunch with your
family is going to be you know may not
be suited for the romantic walk with a
partner or the talk with some business
colleagues and it's worth noting that in
real space in none of these places are
their big visible public signs of
engagement so digital designers could
think about what kind of conversations
do we actually want to invite and how do
we build specifically for those kinds of
conversations
remember the park that we talked about
that built social trust that didn't
happen because people were having these
big political
most strangers don't actually even talk
to each other the first three or four or
five times they see each other but when
people even very different people see
each other a lot they developed
familiarity and that creates the bedrock
for relationships and I think actually
you know maybe that early idea of
cyberspace is kind of this bodyless
meeting place of pure minds and pure
ideas send us off in the wrong direction
maybe what we need instead is to find a
way to be in proximity you know mostly
talking amongst ourselves but all
sharing the same warm Sun and finally
healthy public spaces create a sense of
ownership and equity and this is where
the city metaphor becomes challenging
because if Twitter is a city it's a city
that's owned by just a few people and
optimized for financial return I think
we really need digital environments that
we all actually have some real ownership
of environments that respect the
diversity of human existence and that
give us some say and some input into the
process and I think we need this
urgently because Facebook right now I
sort of think of like 1970s New York the
public spaces are decaying there's trash
in the streets people are kind of like
mentally and emotionally warming
themselves over burning garbage and
and the natural response to this is to
hole up in your apartment or consider
fleeing for the suburbs it doesn't
surprise me that people are giving up on
the idea of online public spaces the way
that they've given up on cities over
their history and sometimes I'll be
honest it feels to me like this whole
project of like wiring up a civilization
and getting billions of people to come
into contact with each other is just
impossible but modern cities tell us
that it is possible for millions of
people who are really different
sometimes living right on top of each
other not just to not kill each other
but to actually build things together
find new experiences create beautiful
important infrastructure and we cannot
give up on that promise if we want to
solve the big important problems in
front of us we need better online public
spaces we need digital urban planners
new Jane Jacobs is who are going to
build the parks and park benches of the
online world and we need digital public
friendly architects who are going to
build when Eric Klinenberg calls palaces
for the people libraries and museums and
town halls and we need a transnational
movement where these faces can learn
from each other just like cities have
about everything from urban farming to
public art to rapid transit humanity
moves forward when we find new ways to
rely on and understand and trust each
other and we need this now more than
ever if online digital spaces are going
to be our new home let's make them a
comfortable beautiful place to live a
place we all feel not just included but
actually some ownership of a place we
get to know each other a place you'd
actually want not just to visit but to
bring your kids thank you
[Applause]
[Music]